-One of our first guests tonight
is an Academy Award-nominated
actor.
The other is
an acclaimed musician.
Starting in February,
they'll be on tour
performing REM's iconic
album "Murmur."
Please welcome to the show
Michael Shannon
and Jason Narducy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Mid-tempo music plays ]
♪♪
Welcome to the show.
-Thank you.
-So this is -- You're
touring classic albums.
You've done this before.
This is not the first time
you've done it.
So I want to talk
about the friendship
and then the idea for the album.
But let's start
with the friendship.
How did you guys first connect?
-We met through a fellow
named Robbie Fulks,
who's an incredible
singer-songwriter.
He was based in Chicago
at the time.
I think he's
moved to L.A. since.
But, yeah, we played --
He had a show, a residency,
where he would play
a different record all the time.
And he wanted to play
this Lou Reed record.
And he asked me to sing it,
and Jason to play bass on it,
and that's how we met, yeah.
-And so you guys,
you basically met
doing some version
of what you're doing now.
-Exactly.
-And when did you do
your first one where it was
just the two of you?
-It was me asking you to do
"Queen is Dead," right?
-Yes, yeah.
-Yeah, we did
"The Queen is Dead"
by the Smiths,
and we did that up in Evanston,
where we all --
-We used to all live
in Evanston, Illinois.
Early '90s.
-Yeah.
-There we go.
Yeah, make some noise, Evanston.
-Yeah.
-You did this one.
You did "Murmur in Chicago
this past summer.
-Yep.
-How long of a show was it?
-Very long. [ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, we knew, going into it,
because "Murmur"
is a pretty short album.
It's under an hour.
And so we also learned
a bunch of other songs,
and we wound up playing
for like three hours.
I mean, there were lots
of little speeches.
-What kind of little speeches?
-Well, the owner of the club,
Joe Shanahan --
we played at Metro.
-Yeah.
And it was also -- it was the
40th anniversary of "Murmur,"
it was the 40th anniversary
of Metro,
and the first show at Metro
was R.E.M.
And it was probably
when they were on tour for this.
-Yeah, yeah.
-So Joe came out
and made some speeches.
He was reminiscing and stuff.
And then --
-He came out after every song.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-"And another thing..."
-Does R.E.M. have any awareness
that you're doing this?
-Well, that night, Mr. --
Can we say?
-Yeah.
-Mr. Mills was there.
-Wow!
-Yeah, yeah.
-Did he appreciate the effort?
-He kept coming up.
-Oh, wow.
-Run up and sing with us.
-Oh, wait, so you actually
had -- That's amazing.
-It's amazing.
-How early did --
How late, I should say,
did you know
he was gonna be there and
maybe singing with you guys?
-He walked into the greenroom
right before we went onstage,
and everybody just
kind of was in shock.
And then Jason's like,
"Do you want to do anything?"
And he's like, "No, I know
you guys have been working
really hard on this.
I'm just here to enjoy it."
And then, about five songs
into the show,
the crowd started cheering
and I'm like,
"Oh, man,
I'm really killing it."
[ Laughter ]
And then I really -- Took me
like a few seconds,
and I turned to my right,
and Mike Mills was standing
there, singing,
and I thought, "Oh,
this has nothing to do with me."
[ Laughter ]
"There's an original member
of the band onstage."
-Pretty great.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-It's so nice to know --
when he showed up
in the greenroom,
did any part of you think
he was there to be like,
"This will not stand!"?
-Yeah.
Or picture him in the
front row just going...
-Yeah.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I will say, it brings me
great joy to know
that his plan was to not,
and that the power of the music,
the opportunity to do it again.
-A couple drinks.
-Yeah, a couple drinks.
Sure, that never hurts.
But that must have been --
I don't know,
it's cool that you guys
made something so magnetic
that he came up
onstage with you.
-I mean, it was an epic night.
I hope we can re-create it
on the tour.
I don't think we're going to
play three hours every night,
because I'll --
[Hoarsely] I'll be like this.
-Yeah, because
you give your all.
-[ Normal voice ] Yeah,
by the last song of the encore,
I was -- thank God,
like five other people
had come up onstage
to sing with us,
because I don't think --
I was pretty close
to life support.
-Yeah, you were giving it all.
-Yeah.
-Obviously, you're the
professional musician here,
and you started at an age
that is truly incredible.
And not just fiddling around.
You were in a band.
How old were you
in your first band?
-I started a band
when I was 10, called Verboten.
-Verboten?
-Yeah.
-By the way, that so speaks
to the era that we grew up.
-Umlauts.
-Umlaut.
If you've got an umlaut
in your band, you rock.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And this is -- I will say,
when I heard you were 10
in a band called Verboten,
I didn't think
you'd look this cool,
because this is, like -- I'd
go see these guys in concert.
-Wow!
[ Laughter ]
-That's you right there, yeah?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This is this is Zach,
this is Chris, this is Tracey.
-Uh-huh.
-These two lived
on the same block as me.
-That's great.
-That's Zach's dad's Volvo
behind us.
[ Laughter ]
-Safety first.
When you got a band that young,
you can't do a van.
You got to do a Volvo.
-Yeah.
-But you played,
like, actual venues.
-Yeah. I'm just so lucky
that I met those guys.
You know, like,
it was such a --
It was a challenging time,
I think, in all of our lives.
And we were kind of, like,
holding each other up
and trying to create
punk rock in 1983.
And Tracey was so charismatic
that she would win over
these other bands.
And so, yeah, we played at the
Cubby Bear in Chicago in 1983,
opening up for a great band
called Naked Raygun.
-And --
-And were your parents
supportive of the idea?
Would they come to gigs?
-I think
they were confused by it.
But, you know,
because I was 11...
[ Laughter ]
...my dad had to drive me
to the show.
-Yeah, yeah.
-And I'm very thankful
that he brought
that 1983 camcorder
and put it on his shoulder
and videotaped us.
-You did bring a camcorder.
We do have video.
And I want to say, on the video,
you guys continue to rock
at a level I did not expect.
Let's take a quick look.
-[ Singing indistinctly ]
♪♪
♪ Ooh ♪
[ Singing indistinctly ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-Urban legend or true story?
A young Dave Grohl
saw this band?
-Yeah, Tracey's family and
Dave's family are really --
They call each other cousins.
-Okay, gotcha.
-And so, when
Dave was 13 years old,
he came with his family
and saw us practice.
And he's very sweet to cite us
as an inspiration to him,
and has even --
he wrote a chapter
in his book "Storyteller"
about Verboten.
And, yeah, it's crazy.
We're all still
really good friends,
which means a lot to me.
But we'll text each other
'cause some book will come out
and it's like, "Check this out.
This band that we had
40 years ago
is -- thanks to Dave Grohl,
is being talked about still."
-That's really amazing.
-Yeah.
-You have -- Yeah,
give it up for Verboten.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We've talked in the past
about your first band
was Jehovah's Suspects.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, I believe you --
You sang "Armadillo Song" here.
That was one of your hits.
And maybe your only song?
-It was the only song I wrote
then.
I was like 15
when I wrote that song.
-Ancient.
-Yeah.
-For these 11-year-old bands,
a 15-year-old...
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I don't know,
we knew three other songs,
but we didn't have --
I was in Kentucky.
We didn't have the scene
like they had in Chicago.
You know, we basically would go
to, like, somebody's barn or --
You know, there were no clubs
that we could go to or anything.
But, yeah, I was more --
I very quickly
leaned towards theater,
because it just seemed like,
frankly, a lot less work.
-Yeah.
In which way?
Like, when you do a school play,
there's more infrastructure?
-You got to do your audition.
And if they give you the part,
you just do your part.
But if you're trying to get
a band going, you know,
it's a lot of work,
a lot of determination.
I think, even more rejection
than you deal with, with acting.
And nobody's gonna --
There's no director
or producer
to take care of you.
You got to figure it all out
yourself, you know?
-Is it true that your dad
made Verboten break up
because he wanted you
to finish sixth grade?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, we did have
a band meeting
with all the parents.
And Tracey -- Tracey was
a little bit older than us.
She was 15, 16, and
she wanted to get a van
and -- and take off,
hit the road.
And my dad was like, "He's gonna
finish sixth grade."
[ Laughter ]
-Usually, in these stories,
you take the side of the band.
You're like, "Hey, old man,
you don't get it!"
But now that I have kids,
I'm like, "Yeah,
you got to finish sixth."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Well, the funny thing now
is that my dad works
in a bookstore,
and when a customer comes up
with a book that we're in,
he's just like,
"Please turn to page 209."
[ Laughter ]
And you know, you can imagine
being a book shopper
and you're kind of flipping
through like, "Why?
Why am I doing this?"
And then he just puts his finger
on my name in the book,
and they go,
"I don't know who that is."
[ Laughter ]
-It must be really special
for him.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, they go,
"I don't know who this is,"
Just like the audience did
when I walked out here.
[ Laughter ]
-It'll be cool
for him to watch this tonight
and be like, "Look at that.
No recognition."
-Yeah, well,
it's impenetrable pride.
-Yeah. There you go.
I love it.
A dad proud of his kid's
rock 'n' roll band
all these years later
is a pretty cool thing.
You have facial hair right now
going on
that you want to explain
real quick.
-And fingernails.
-Oh, yeah, the fingernails.
-If you see them tonight during
the show, don't be alarmed.
They're for a play I'm doing
right now,
called "Waiting for Godot."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, thanks. Hey.
Right on.
Yeah, Jason came to see it
last night.
Most of the band did, actually.
It was awfully nice of you.
And we're going
till December 23rd.
Or the precipice of Christmas,
as I like to refer to it.
-Yeah.
You've always called it that.
-Yes, December 23rd is --
-A lot of people only start
talking -- they're
like "Christmas Eve,"
and you're like, no, you got to
go one day before that."
I like the precipice.
-Yeah. Add that doom feeling.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
"Eve" is too hopeful,
whereas, like, "precipice,"
I feel like is a truer bounce
for what you're about to happen.
-We're falling, yes, yes.
-I am glad
because I do also feel --
and don't take this
the wrong way, Michael --
I feel like if you came out
with those fingernails
and that beard,
a lot of people
wouldn't think it was a play.
[ Laughter ]
-That's true. That's true.
It's my COVID look.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Everyone's like,
"Oh, he doesn't know
we're on the other side of it."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-And you guys are going to do
a song for us
from your performance,
from your show.
I can't wait to see it.
You guys,
that is Michael Shannon,
that is Jason Narducy.
For tickets to their tour --
and it's going to be amazing --
visit concertedefforts.com.
They'll be performing
later in the show.
Stick around.
We'll be right back
with Rachel Bloom, everybody.